the only way is essex star lauren
goodger's infant daughter lorena has
died lauren makes the heartbreaking
announcement on her instagram page
sharing a picture of her baby's hand
touching her fingers
in the caption she reveals lorena died
on july 8th
sharing quote she was the most beautiful
healthy baby i've ever seen just like
her sister words can't describe as a
mother losing your baby that i carried
for all these months perfectly and gave
birth to for my angel to be taken from
me lauren also posted a broken heart
emoji to her instagram story along with
celine dion's emotional song the prayer
[Music]
lauren doesn't reveal lorena's cause of
death but does explain there was no
pregnancy or labor complications
quote there was nothing wrong with her
or myself she was perfect i can't
understand it
she expresses her love for lorena
calling her so beautiful and says she'll
be with her always
she also shares she's back home from the
hospital and asks for privacy as she
grieves
fans first met lauren in 2010 as one of
the original cast members on the british
reality tv series the only way is essex
i love you as a mother and you know
you've been like a mum to me and i want
everyone to support us you know and i
know it's hard i just think they do
everybody does support you we all
support you after appearing on the show
on and off for years lauren went on to
compete on celebrity big brother in the
uk wow killer feedback lauren it's
obvious how much she wants to win but
when it comes to lauren's personal life
she started dating boyfriend charles
drury in 2020 they welcomed their first
child a baby girl named larose in 2021
and in january lauren revealed that she
was pregnant again in may the reality
star opened up about adding another
little one to their growing family i'm
so comfortable
but i wouldn't have it any other way
because i'm so grateful that i've got
another beautiful gift a little sister
for the rose and then we're very close
and i'm glad that i've done it this way
lauren writes on instagram that through
it all larose has been helping her heal
quote i just need this time with my baby
girl a rose she is my rock that's
getting me through this or i wouldn't
survive